un último intenso cara a cara previa la
segunda vuelta electoral de las
presidenciales brasileñas a la izquierda
el ex presidente Luis Ignacio lulada
Silva quien lidera los sondeos con 6
puntos de ventaja a la derecha su rival
el mandatario Yair bolsonaro quien Busca
la reelección
la violencia conmigo disminuyó mucho en
tu gobierno solo subió desde casumiste
en 2003 hasta 2006 aumentaron de media
un 30% los homicidios en Brasil qué
hicimos nosotros para revertir eso al
contrario que tú Yo no fui a visitar a
traficantes
por armas de fuego armas portadas por
bandidos y no por ciudadanos de bien
y del otro lado de la pantalla una
nación altamente polarizada algo que
sabía en ambos candidatos que durante el
debate se lanzaron constantes ataques
directos y acusaciones desacreditándose
en mi gobierno va a hacer lo siguiente
vamos a pedir autorización a las fuerzas
armadas y vamos a fisca porque el crimen
organizado no puede en nombre de la
liberalización de armas estar haciéndose
con un Arsenal más competente que el de
la policía
pese a esto algunos de los temas
tratados fueron desde la corrupción las
relaciones políticas con otras naciones
la economía interna hasta las tasas de
pobreza de Brasil los analistas
señalaban que este debate es crucial
para esa gran parte del electorado que
todavía se considera como indecisos el
55% de los brasileños afirman que la
televisada contienda es muy importante
para su decisión una respuesta que la
cuarta democracia más grande del mundo
sabrá el domingo